[Música]
estamos aquí en la feria internacional
del libro en la ciudad de bogotá para
directo américa estamos aquí entonces
haciendo un par de entrevistas
entrevistando a las personalidades
invitadas a esta feria del libro
internacional en esta oportunidad me
acompaña guillermo rivera él es ex
ministro del interior del gobierno del
ex presidente juan manuel santos estuvo
lucrado en todo lo que fue el proceso de
paz con una ex guerrilla de la farc
también fue congresista y pues un
político de colombia gracias ministro
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 gracias a ustedes
por la invitación estás aquí ministro
presentando el libro entre risas y
prisas cuatro años de intento para
acabar el acuerdo de paz
que está en las prisas que está acabado
y que es lo gracioso
no realmente la frase no es mía la frase
es del presidente duque que cuando fue
candidato presidencial dijo que con el
acuerdo de paz ni trizas ni risas
entonces yo un poco recojo esa frase y
lo que le digo es estos cuatro años de
su gobierno del gobierno de guandú que
en los que ha intentado acabar el
acuerdo de paz pues el acuerdo de paz ha
estado entre tristes y risas entre
trizas porque si lo quiso hacer trizas
pero también entre risas porque lo ha
dejado en gran medida al garete y al
olvido y por eso recojo su frase para
titular el libro actualmente como el
proceso de paz como como va la
implementación muy mal realmente muy mal
creo que estos cuatro años dejan un
sabor muy amargo en cuanto a la
implementación del acuerdo de paz y la
razón por la cual se han incrementado
los homicidios se han incrementado las
masacres los secuestros
el desplazamiento forzado es porque este
gobierno se ha negado a implementar
integralmente el acuerdo de paz falta
voluntad política en el país para que
realmente simplemente sin duda yo creo
que lo que ha brillado por su ausencia
es la voluntad política del gobierno de
conducta ahorita en colombia tenemos las
elecciones presidenciales que puede
cambiar
bueno esperamos que quien gane la
presidencia asuma un compromiso de
implementar el acuerdo de paz hay
candidatos que lo han expresado
de manera muy clara y hay uno que no
que sigue teniendo una visión muy
similar a la que tiene o en duke y bueno
creo que si federico gutiérrez es
elegido presidente vamos a estar en
serios problemas con el acuerdo de paz
institucionalmente como puede hacer
colombia para que este acuerdo realmente
se respete y sobre todo a las víctimas
que son las que más han sufrido este
conflicto armada más de 40 y 50 años
digamos que el acuerdo tiene que
respetarse porque tiene tiene un
blindaje constitucional enorme la propia
constitución dice que el acuerdo no se
puede
deshacer en lo esencial que el tres
gobiernos
seguidos deben respetar
eso eso que está previsto en el acuerdo
pero
así se respete digamos lo que está
previsto formalmente se requiere
implementar y eso implica voluntad
política que es lo que creo que no ha
habido en este gobierno y es lo que
esperamos exista en el gobierno que
empiece el 7 de agosto que realmente se
necesita para que este acuerdo se
implemente digamos a nivel país a nivel
institucional porque pues vemos que como
usted lo dice lo digo también no se ha
terminado a respetar este acuerdo así
sea que está blindado por la
constitución pues muy bonito en el papel
pero en la práctica no se está haciendo
nada para realmente implementarlo y que
sea una paz duradera una paz real en
este país no yo sí creo que lo que hace
falta es voluntad política digamos está
el acuerdo y hay una ruta
pero para seguir esa ruta hay que tener
voluntad política hay que tener decisión
y el gobierno de iván tocante a la
comunidad internacional posa como un
defensor de la paz pero cuando está aquí
no hace sino cuestionar criticar
aspectos que son esenciales del acuerdo
de paz y en otros que también son
esenciales del acuerdo de paz no hecho
nada por ejemplo no ha presentado el
proyecto de ley de desarrollo rural que
es un proyecto de ley fundamental para
el acuerdo de paz
engavetaron los decretos que se habían
expedido en el gobierno anterior para
proteger a las comunidades que están en
riesgo
y digamos que todo ese tipo de
iniciativas requieren un compromiso
genuino del gobierno y eso es lo que no
ha existido en este gobierno y lo que
esperamos exista a partir del 7 de
agosto de este año
aquí se debe entonces este incremento de
la violencia a esa falta de la paz a esa
falta de implementación a esa falta de
implementación del acuerdo de paz se
debe que la violencia haya crecido el
acuerdo de paz se firmó en el año 2016
entre el año 2016 y el 2018
colombia vivió un momento muy especial
las cifras de los homicidios del
desplazamiento forzado de los secuestros
cayeron y fueron las más bajas de los
últimos 40 años del 2019 en adelante han
vuelto a crecer y claramente sucede ve a
la ausencia de implementación del
acuerdo qué pasa con él ln se puede
realmente llegar también a un acuerdo de
paz como se llegó con una descarrilló de
las farc en algún momento a lo mejor con
otro gobierno que venga en este país
pues yo creo que hay que buscar la paz
con el ln en el gobierno anterior estuvo
incluso muy cerca de firmarse un acuerdo
bilateral indefinido de cese al fuego y
hay rumores hay muchas versiones que
señalan que fue el gobierno
o personas cercanas ayudando que una vez
elegido antes de tomar posesión del
cargo quienes convencieron a la ln de no
suscribir ese acuerdo con el argumento
pues de que ya empezaba un nuevo
gobierno y fíjense que si eso es cierto
pues fue realmente una muy mala decisión
porque él lln ha crecido en colombia
y pues ha provocado más víctimas si
hubiésemos logrado la firma de un
acuerdo de cese al fuego a lo mejor se
habría podido desatar un acuerdo de paz
con el el en qué tan difícil fue regular
ese acuerdo de paz firmado en el 2016
esa negociación con una guerrilla de la
farc que no se ha dicho fue muy difícil
yo realmente no fui negociador a mí me
correspondió más la tarea de la
implementación del acuerdo pero sin duda
quienes estuvieron en la habana cinco
años pues sí hicieron un esfuerzo enorme
y fue muy complejo lograr superar ese
conflicto lograr unos acuerdos mínimos
que fue lo que finalmente se pactó en en
la habana fueron cinco años imagínense
ustedes cinco años de dedicación
exclusiva
y en el que cinco años en los que se
abordaron digamos los temas que había
que abordar para lograr un acuerdo yo yo
siento que
y además humberto de la calle que fue el
jefe negociador lo ha dicho colombia ha
tenido en los últimos años dos hitos
democráticos la constitución de 1991 y
luego el acuerdo de paz
y desafortunadamente ni la constitución
se ha desarrollado totalmente y como se
debería desarrollar y respetando su
espíritu liberal progresista pero
también hay que decir que el acuerdo de
paz que es el otro hito democrático
tampoco se ha implementado luego digamos
tenemos dos referentes democráticos que
no se han desarrollado cabalmente y las
consecuencias saltan a la vista el
incremento de la violencia la
insatisfacción social pero ahí hay un
par hay un par de cartas de navegación
que el gobierno que empieza en el año
2020 en este año perdón el 7 de agosto
ojalá las asuma con total
responsabilidad usted cree que ese
trabajo se ha perdido esos 5 años de
negociación ese acuerdo de paz del
trabajo que usted hizo para la
implementación de este acuerdo que como
pues estamos conversando acá
no ha sido de la mejor manera si se
puede decir se perdió ese trabajo que
hicieron ustedes no yo no creo que se
haya perdido yo yo he venido diciendo y
a propósito del lanzamiento de este
libro si he dicho que colombia tiene ya
una única oportunidad
de no perder ese esfuerzo que ha
significado el acuerdo de paz
y esa oportunidad es que el gobierno que
llegue el 7 de agosto se decida a
implementar el acuerdo si hay un
gobierno que no lo haga si me temo que
vamos a perder esa oportunidad
se puede llegar a eso si el gobierno que
llega el próximo 7 de agosto no se pone
las pilas y dice vamos a trabajar por
este acuerdo vamos a trabajar por la paz
que tanto necesita colombia no lo hacen
el trabajo si se perdió yo creo que se
podría perder yo creo que se podría
perder porque otros cuatro años
sin que haya una implementación integral
del acuerdo pues es muy probable que
entremos en una nueva fase o en una fase
distinta de violencia que sería muy
peligrosa para colombia de hecho hay un
libro de francisco gutiérrez que habla
sobre eso digamos sobre los riesgos de
que entremos en una nueva fase de
violencia en colombia
y estamos en un punto de inflexión nos
parece que este es el momento en el que
hay que acudir al acuerdo de paz e
implementarlo con toda la convicción y
de manera íntegra ministro ya para
finalizar nuestra conversación que
rescata de su libro para nuestra vista
internacional que puede encontrar aquí
que no conozca digamos de este conflicto
tan tan tan grave que ha sufrido
colombia por muchísimo tiempo la
violencia de colombia que puede
encontrar acá
pues yo diría que no hay nada que no se
haya dicho lo que pasa es que en el
libro lo que sí hago es tratar de
describir las emociones que se vivieron
durante la negociación del acuerdo de
paz durante su implementación
la experiencia con la ley de víctimas
que fue como un preámbulo a la
negociación de paz en fin ahí hay eso
digamos la persona que prologó el libro
dice que en el fondo se trata de un
texto que es una montaña rusa emocional
porque vamos de momentos de mucha
esperanza de mucha ilusión a momentos de
mucho escepticismo de de mucha
frustración también entonces el libro es
un poco eso es una narración
de las emociones que vivimos durante la
negociación durante la implementación y
yo diría también en épocas muy difíciles
que vivió el país como
los años finales de la década de 1980 o
de los años 80
el país era casi inviable viene la
expedición de la constitución de 1991
una gran esperanza una gran ilusión y
luego también otra frustración luego la
gran ilusión del acuerdo de paz luego
otra frustración con su implementación y
así no la hemos pasado en colombia ojalá
en algún momento
ya no estamos en una montaña rusa
emocional sino en yo diría en un
corredor de esperanza de ilusión de fe y
ojalá de felicidad algún día y que
finalmente llegue la paz así es también
ese tiene que ser el propósito pues
ojalá llegue ministro gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
francés y 4 aquí está su libro entre
tristes y risas cuatro años de intentos
por acabar el acuerdo de paz gracias por
su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 a ustedes
muchas gracias